deutschland deutschland will jetzt doch
panzer und schweres gerät an die ukraine
liefern letzte woche noch war das dem
kanzler zu riskant er warnte vor der
gefahr eines atomkrieges eines dritten
weltkrieges was oder wer hat ihn zum
umdenken gebracht setzt der westen und
nun auch deutschland auf einen
militärischen sieg der ukraine auch
darüber wollen wir reden mit diesen
gästen
robert habeck vizekanzler und
bundeswirtschaftsminister
der cdu vorsitzende und
oppositionsführer friedrich merz
lars klingbeil vorsitzender der spd
die russland expertin sabine fischer
ben hodges ehemaliger kommandeur der us
landstreitkräfte in europa und die
leiterin des spiegel hauptstadtbüros
melanie amann sie sind zu gast bei
maybrit illner
und einen gästen ein herzliches
willkommen gehe heute abend los geht's
gar keine waffen nur defensivwaffen
keine schweren waffen keine panzer sie
kennen diese vorbehalte alle sie sind
plötzlich wie weggeblasen
jetzt also doch die bundesregierung gibt
grünes licht für die lieferung von 50
gepaart flugabwehr panzern genau das was
die ukraine jetzt braucht um den
luftraum zu sichern vom boden aus schon
ende februar hatte die industrie alte
ausgemusterte gepaart angeboten
doch kanzler olaf scholz zögerte auch
hier wie bei den 100 mördern und die
seit wochen gegen
die einwände waren zahlreich
die bundeswehr brauche die mörder selbst
sie seien kaputt im übrigen sei das
gerät zu komplex eine notwendige
schulung dauere zu lange und lieferung
lieber nur im ring tausch mit anderen
nato partnern
zuletzt formulierte der bundeskanzler
diesen grund
ich tue alles um eine eskalation zu
verhindern die zu einem dritten
weltkrieg führt es darf keinen atomkrieg
geben
die schweren waffen nicht zu liefern
empörte viele auch aus den eigenen
reihen
keine darf den krieg nicht verlieren
russland auf den krieg nicht gewinnen
wir müssen alles was in unserer macht
steht tun um der ukraine zum sieg zu
verhelfen
doch das passiert nicht anton hofreiter
formulierte wo das problem liegt das
problem ist im kanzleramt
und der vizekanzler ist bei uns heute
abend guten abend robert habeck
folgender guten abend wir haben das
verfolgt kommen sie noch hinterher
gestern war eine solche panzerlieferung
noch auslese für einen möglichen
atomkrieg gar den dritten weltkrieg
jetzt liefern wir geparden
verstehen sie es noch
man muss die situation in der härte
einmal formulieren putin handelt nicht
mehr wirklichkeit bezogen und in dem
sinne rational er hat sich über die
wirklichkeit permanent hinweggetäuscht
er hat gedacht die ukraine freut sich
auf die russische befreiung keiner will
die russen in der ukraine haben er hat
gedacht die russische armee ist sehr
stark das hat sich am anfang ebenfalls
des krieges als falsch herausgestellt
hat die ukrainische armee unterschätzt
er hat die entschlossenheit des westens
unterschätzt hat auch die bereitschaft
deutschlands unterschätzt waffen zu
liefern also ein mensch der die
wirklichkeit komplett falsch einschätzt
und er hat atomwaffen ein mensch der die
wirklichkeit falsch einschätzt mit
atomwaffen deswegen ist es natürlich ein
bedrohliches szenario
und das muss man auch so ernst nehmen
und immer mit bedenken und andererseits
haben wir wirklich der lieferung von
schweren waffen weitere unterstützung
für die ukraine beschlossen und jetzt
verstehe ich es immer noch nicht es gibt
menschen die sagen die
gründe und argumente waren so zahlreich
wie deutschland überhaupt
funktionierende panzer hat um zu
erklären oder auch nicht zu erklären
warum wir
diese schweren waffen nicht zur
verfügung stellen wollen es ist ein
unterschied ein substanzieller
unterschied ob man sagt ich kann nicht
oder ich will nicht es hat beide
argumentationen gegeben die sich munter
abwechselten und eben zuletzt wurde mit
einem weltkrieg gedroht das ist jetzt
nicht mehr die gefahr
es gibt eine abstrakte gefahr dass es
eine eskalation des krieges gibt und
damit sie nicht konkret wird muss jede
entscheidung sehr besonnen
getroffen werden und als ich vor fünf
tagen ich glaube es war auch jetzt auf
ihrem kanal im zdf ähnliches gefragt
wurde habe ich schon gesagt wir kümmern
uns schon um die lieferung schwerer
waffen das heißt wir sind ja nicht erst
heute entschieden schwere waffen zu
liefern sondern mit der eskalation des
krieges auch mit der taktischen
verlagerung des krieges in die offene
stelle weg von dem häuserkampf hinzu
panzerschlachten wie wir sie eigentlich
nur aus düstersten zeiten der
europäischen geschichte kennen musste
auch die unterstützung des westens
europas und deutschlands
nachgezogen werden und das heißt es
müssen auch schwere waffen geliefert
werden der mit rheinischem standhalten
kann warum wünscht sich nicht nur die
ukraine das deutschland bitte nicht
immer das schlusslicht ist bei richtig
empfundenen entscheidungen also
andersrum gefragt warum bringt sich wenn
das so ist wie sie sagen der
bundeskanzler in den ruch ein image zu
haben nicht zu entscheiden zögerlich zu
entscheiden und gerne als letzter der
nato-partner dass die ukraine mehr will
und zwar die volle unterstützung
inklusive schließung des luftraums und
überwachung dieser schließung mit
nato-kampfjets das verstehe ich wenn ich
ukrainischer politiker wäre ich würde
das gleiche fordern wenn man im krieg
ist und zwar in solch ein krieg wo ja
die bevölkerung
abgeschlachtet wird dann kann eine
unterstützung nie genug sein das
verstehe ich vollständig für aus der
sicht aus deutscher sicht aus westlicher
sicht aus europäischer sicht muss man
eben andere kriterien mit einbeziehen
das ist keine einfache entscheidung und
auch keine wo man mit blütenreiner weste
rauskommt aber natürlich wäre eine
eskalation des krieges auf europäischen
grund einen türen von deutschland in den
krieg als kriegspartei eine katastrophe
das können wir auch nicht wollen vor
diesem hintergrund muss man eben klug
abwägen und die richtigen entscheidungen
treffen und sie sind das jetzt passiert
und ich finde es eigentlich einmal sagen
darf gut wenn eine regierung die
argumente miteinander weckt und dann zu
den gemeinsam getragene entscheidung
kommt und das haben wir heute im
bundestag gesehen dass die regierung
stark geschlossen und und entschieden
ist so wenn die verbündeten unsere
verbündeten wenn die ukraine so dankbar
für das deutsche engagement gewesen wäre
dann hätte sie es wahrscheinlich auch
ein bisschen lauter gesagt ich frag doch
mal heute ist der bundeskanzler
aufmacher im time magazine und das ist
keine gute geschichte das ist eine
geschichte wo der deutschen regierung
unterstellt wird dass sie zögerlich war
dass sie diesen krieg geben und die
ukraine nicht so unterstützt hat wie sie
es könnte noch mal die frage auch an dem
vizekanzler und wirtschaftsminister wie
sehr schadet dieses image auch in all
ihren gesprächen habe
natürlich muss man zugeben dass die
berichterstattung jetzt in den letzten
tagen und wochen nicht berühmter für uns
das wäre albern darüber hinweg zu reden
das hat auch einen grund die werde ich
durch erläutern aber einmal möchte ich
noch festhalten dass deutschland mit der
lieferung der waffen sich ungefähr im
korridor der alliierten bewegt und zwar
ungefähr im oberen im oberen kräftefeld
die
gleich nebenan gibt eine andere es gibt
einen anderen grund habe ich will es
einmal sagen die anderen alliierten die
westlichen länder liefern auch keine
kampfpanzer aus eigener westlicher
bauart was an schweren kampfpanzern
geliefert wird sind panzer sowjetischer
bauart und die wir einander sehr
das ist ja nun der öffentlichkeit alles
nachträglich und vorträge ich schon
erklärt worden
ich will nur sagen also auch die
amerikaner haben noch keine keine
amerikanischen panzer dahin geliefert
und die franzosen auch nicht insofern
sind wir ungefähr in dem maß dabei wie
eine klassenfahrt nach einstimmung uns
auch die der grundform deutschland dorf
appliance besondere eine besondere
besonders angeguckt wird hat ist ein
doppelter würde ich denken erstens wir
sind ein sehr rüstungs starkes land wir
sind eine rüstungsschmiede nation und
haben waffen an viele länder geliefert
wo man auch manchmal schlucken musste
und sagte echt jetzt muss das jetzt
notwendig seien und deswegen werden wir
natürlich anders gemessen weil wir diese
starke rüstungsindustrie haben als
andere länder die diese starken
rüstungsindustrie nicht haben die
erwartungen sind einfach höher die
gründe warum es da eine gewisse
zurückhaltung gibt die habe ich eben
ausgeführt und das ist jetzt keine
gründe auf die man super stolz sein kann
aber es sind eben gründe die man auch
anerkennen muss und der zweite grund ist
dass deutschland in der jüngsten
vergangenheit ich werde jetzt nicht über
historische schuld zweiter weltkrieg und
die gräueltaten die die wehrmacht auf
ukrainischem russischen belarussischen
polnischem boden und weiter
begangen hat sondern in den letzten zehn
jahren hat deutschland in der energie-
und wirtschaftspolitik einen sehr
russlandfreundlichen kurs gefahren ein
kurs der auch die ukraine schon in den
letzten jahren cup held hat wenn man in
kiew haben alle ukrainischen politiker
gesagt was seid ihr eigentlich für
nachbarn oder alliierte ihr bock nostrum
2 ihr helft uns nicht mit waffen hier
unterstützt uns nicht in die nato nach
europa zu kommen und deswegen wir
starten im minus wir haben in der
vergangenheit uns zu sehr an russland
orientiert auf russland ausgerichtet in
der energiepolitik ist es ja inzwischen
erkannt und durchdacht und deswegen
haben wir eine größere bringschuld in
der erwartungshaltung der ukraine sie
haben sich zu diesen energiepolitischen
fragen viel geäußert und viel äußern
müssen wir haben jetzt nicht mehr ganz
so viel zeit für exakt eigentlich ihren
bisher habe ich wann kommt das
öl-embargo sie haben darum sehr gerungen
an den verschiedensten stellen nächste
woche treffen sich die 27 eu staaten
welche ankündigung wird es da geben das
weiß ich nicht genau man muss jetzt auch
zwei dinge auseinanderhalten auch wenn
das manchmal etwas schwerfällt ich habe
es eben schon gesagt die erste aufgabe
ist nicht erpressbar zu sein von putin
dass er also sagt wie unterstützt die
ukraine dann drehe ich euch gas oder öl
ab da sind wir beide jetzt deutlich
vorangekommen und können deswegen auch
ein embargo mitgehen wenn es denn käme
die zweite frage ist wie klug ist ein
embargo aufgesetzt und da das habe ich
schon immer wieder gesagt ist die
schnelle emotionen jetzt bestrafen wie
putin gekauft und sein öl nicht mehr es
kann aber eine situation eintreten dass
dann weil da die ölmenge fehlt auf dem
weltmarkt die preise sehr nach oben
gehen und putin der dann noch öl an
andere staaten verkauft mit weniger öl
mehr geld bekommt das wäre natürlich
dass wir natürlich eine idiotie weil es
ab und ist der kontraproduktiv das gilt
es zu verhindern
und erst recht gilt es zu verhindern
dass der ölpreis weltweit so steigt das
sich nur noch deutschland westeuropa und
die usa und kanada vielleicht sich das
leisten können alle anderen sagen
wirtschaftskrise wir können nicht mehr
auto fahren und dann meldet sich putin
und sagt ja da seht ihr mal was passiert
der kapitalistische westen macht euch
arm ich helfe euch aus und bei wirklich
dennoch 20 discount ich will nur dass
ihr meine alliierten seite und auf
einmal teilen wir die welt in alliierte
von russland auf oder schon kann ihm
neue alliierten und weil wir ein
ölembargo machen langer rede kurzer sinn
deutschland steht dem nicht im weg wir
sind deutlich vorangekommen wie sind
frei zu entscheiden wie wir es wollen
ist von der rumpeln es wird noch immer
preissprung gegeben das ist jetzt nicht
umgeschmolzen zu haben dass sich niemand
täuscht da es wird lieferausfälle geben
wäre es morgen soweit und wir werden
enorme preissprünge haben also das tut
noch immer ordentlich weh aber wir
werden keine nationale katastrophe mehr
erleben insofern können wir frei
diskutieren was jetzt sinnvoll ist der
ukraine zu helfen ob ein nur einseitiges
öl embargo der erste schritt ist das
habe ich eben angedeutet da habe ich
zumindestens nachfragen aber es gibt
auch andere möglichkeiten und diese
anderen möglichkeiten werde ich heute
abend hier nicht ausbreiten ich kann
ihnen aber versichern dass die
alliierten darüber nachdenken und klug
darüber nachdenken wie man russland
weiter schadet um diesen krieg endlich
einzustellen letzte frage wenn sie das
so zusammenfassende herbeck mit der
bitte um eine kurze antwort der
finanzminister christian bender ist zu
zitieren mit dem satz die ukraine muss
diesen krieg gewinnen und wir müssen sie
ertüchtigen sagt dass auch der
vizekanzler und glauben sie olaf scholz
würde das genauso sein ja wir sagen alle
das gleiche ich würde es negativ
formulieren russland darf nicht gewinnen
und die ukraine darf nicht verlieren und
nicht gewinnen ist etwas anderes als man
muss verlieren die idee das ukrainische
truppen dann moskau einnehmen um den
sieg zu vollenden dies natürlich auch
absurd aber putin darf sich in der
ukraine nicht durchsetzen das ist
eindeutig und
damit willkommen und zurück in der runde
lars klingbeil putin möchte und
formuliert dass der westen jetzt einen
stellvertreterkrieg führt in der ukraine
das ist die nachricht des abends heißt
im umkehrschluss dass er der nato
unterstellt einen krieg gegen russland
als solches zu führen heißt joe biden
ist zu zitieren mit dem gedanken der
westen wird gegebenenfalls mehr liefern
müssen eingedenk der tatsache was heute
passiert ist wäre die sozialdemokratie
überhaupt in der lage mehr waffen als
dem gepard mehr waffen als vielleicht
irgendwann den marder und die leopards
mieter also punkt 1 assist putin der
diesen krieg begonnen hat und den führt
und putin ist verantwortlich für diesen
krieg und wir alle gucken auf die
entwicklung wir alle hoffen dass dieser
krieg vorbei ist aber wir müssen nehmen
auch zur kenntnis nehmen dass haben sie
angesprochen dass
während scheint es mit jemandem zu tun
ein kreml der zumindest stellenweise
nicht berechenbar ist und der auch
bereit ist zu eskalieren und deswegen
glaube ich müssen wir uns bewusst machen
dass jeder schritt den wir gehen das
überlegt sein muss und so zur frage
können wir noch mehr liefern ich bin
erstmal froh und dankbar dass wir heute
in der mitte des parlamentes ein zu
breiten beschluss auch mit der union
zusammen gefasst haben und das war ein
gutes signal dass wir das heute getan
haben
und im jahr hat wer suchet diese findet
also
verteidigungsministerium hat gesucht und
gefunden ist plötzlich gegen das neue
der ist ja 2011 jetzt fangen wir mal aus
seiner verantwortung getragen hat und so
weiter so ausgemustert worden da hat man
die heeres flugabwehr nicht mehr
gebraucht anscheinend und ja wir sind
was die bestände der bundeswehr angeht
sind wir ziemlich am ende das ist
deutlich geworden wir haben keine
bundeswehr die voll ausgestattet ist das
ist gerade ein problem wir haben die
industrie die noch restbestände hat
altbestände da ist jetzt die frage
nutzen wir die für den ringtausch zum
beispiel bei den malern das halte ich
für sinnvoll aber es ist begrenzt was
wir überhaupt noch ein militärischem
gerät liefern können fangen wir damit an
friedrich merz auch sie zu fragen
gegebenenfalls werden wir zügig mehr
liefern müssen als wir bisher geliefert
haben weil unabhängig von der debatte
der letzten acht wochen ist die union
dazu bereits beispielsweise wenn sie
markus söder zu hören wir haben heute im
deutschen bundestag einen gemeinsamen
beschluss gefasst dass wir überhaupt mal
klarheit verschaffen in der frage ob wir
und was wir liefern wir haben ja einen
wochenlangen streit in dieser frage
gesehen ob wir überhaupt wollen und ob
wir überhaupt können und dazwischen
hatte es in der regierung jede position
gegeben seit heute ist das jetzt
einigermaßen klar und ich finde da hat
lars klingbeil recht es ist gut dass
diese klarheit besteht ist es übrigens
auch gut dass der deutsche bundestag
sich zu dieser frage einmal geäußert hat
und nicht nur die bundesregierung
und jetzt hoffen wir alle dass dieser
krieg irgendwann auch zu seinem ende
entgegen geht die russische armee ist
schwächer als gedacht
die ukrainische armee ist sehr viel
stärker und erfolgreicher als gedacht
und insofern bleiben wir doch mal
zunächst bei dem was wir heute
beschlossen und erreicht haben bevor wir
über die nächste eskalation sprechen wir
alle hoffen dass es diese eskalation
nicht gibt und wir alle hoffen dass
dieses ja war bayerische schlachten der
menschen aufhört bei uns ist melanie
amann hauptstadtstudio leiterin vom
spiegel mitglied der chefredaktion vor
allem an sie haben interessanterweise in
den letzten wochen zwei interviews
geführt mit olaf scholz dem
bundeskanzler der ihnen ins platz am
letzten freitag noch notierte und sagte
dass in dritter weltkrieg droht und das
eine eskalation eines atomkrieges zu
vermeiden ist als grund für das nicht
liefern schwere waffen
ist für sie nachvollziehbar was da jetzt
geschehen ist es ist nachvollziehbar
aber es ist schon seltsam und auch
beunruhigend also das interview das wir
geführt haben war keine drei tage alt
liegt jetzt noch am kiosk mit der
position
dass olaf scholz sagt im prinzip wenn
wir schwere waffen liefern stellte das
in den kontext der gefahr eines
atomkrieges und das ist eine seiner
neuen wichtigsten argumente gewesen
diese lieferung auszuschließen und
während dieses heft noch liegt denn
diese diese ausgabe hat die
bundesregierung schon den neuen kurs
eingeschlagen und wie kann man sich das
erklären also ich denke schon dass da
die olaf scholz zeitenwende sozusagen
eingeleitet wurde durch den enormen
internationalen druck durch die
beobachtung wie der krieg sich verändert
hat dass eben die schweren waffen jetzt
so notwendig werden noch wichtiger
werden durch dieses treffen in ramstein
mit dem internationalen bündnis partner
des vereins nämlich eine konferenz von
den usa und deutschland wird eingeladen
in ramstein im eigenen land quasi auf
der amerikanischen base mitzumachen und
da hätte man es vielleicht wenn scholz
nicht gegengesteuert hätte wenn
lambrecht nicht gegengesteuert hätte es
so ausgesehen dass wir eben nicht
gemütlich im mainstream der
bündnispartner schwimmen und sagen
können ja die liefern ja alle auch nicht
mehr und wir machen doch nur das was
alle anderen machen das alles abgestimmt
dieses narrativ hätte da durchaus kaputt
gehen können und da war es glaube ich
wirklich nach dem scholz schon mit dem
rücken zur wand stand jetzt der
befreiungsschlag jetzt eben doch sich
durchzuringen welche rolle spielt in
ihren augen die opposition und der
zweite antrag der union in genau diesem
fall ich denke schon dass das mit ein
faktor war also dass da schon friedrich
merz wie es die aufgabe eines
oppositionsführers ist den kanzler vor
sich her getrieben hat also der antrag
der union war sicher ein
innenpolitischer faktor mit dem die
regierung ganz bitter hätte vorgeführt
werden können im bundestag wenden
ist bei diesen getrennten anträgen
geblieben wäre und sich vielleicht
gezeigt hätte dass der ein oder andere
ampel abgeordnete da sich womöglich
hätte umstimmen lassen zumindest sich zu
enthalten also dass sie jetzt für die
union gestimmt hätten das halte ich für
ausgeschlossen aber das wäre doch eine
sehr peinliche situation vielleicht eine
dramatische situation herr klingbeil
denken sie dass das der grund war
entschuldigung wenn ich das so blöd
frage dass das der grund war für olaf
scholz wirklich eine 180 grad wende also
im grunde schon wieder eine zeitenwende
zu machen und so etwas war gestern noch
begründet hat wenn die fertigung die
einen ist er ein bisschen also der
kontext dritter weltkrieg und das muss
einfach sagen die gefahr ist der real da
die gefahr ist real da dass putin diesen
krieg weiter eskaliert die gefahr ist
sehr real da dass der westen das sind
die nato staaten einbezogen werden in
diesem konflikt also ich möchte den
gegen ihr leben der das gerade komplett
ausschließt dass putin bereit wäre
diesen weg zu gehen und ich sag dir mal
die menschen in diesem land haben angst
davor
das zweite ist dass olaf scholz im
spiegel interview die frage dritter
weltkrieg in den kontext flugverbotzone
gesetzt hat mit der frage auch stellen
wir der ukraine kampfjets zur verfügung
die diese die flugverbotszone einhalten
das ist ja ein schritt den geht kein
westlicher staat gerade dem
trotzdem haben eigentlich das manöver
lesen macht wenn das haben sie gerade
nach schweren gefragt zum beispiel und
waffen möchte ich gerne das dritte was
ich einordnen möchte das hat der rat
auch richtigerweise gesagt es gibt kein
westliches land oder es gibt kein
westliches land das bis zum wochenende
davon geredet hat westliche panzer zu
liefern wir haben immer davon gesprochen
dass die sowjetische panzer weil wir
doch wissen dass die ukrainischen
soldatinnen und soldaten sofort in der
lage sind sich da rein zu setzen und die
dinger zu bedienen ja das ist bei den
panzern die wir haben schwierig oder
muss erst eine ausbildung stattfinden
das hat kein staat gemacht bis dahin
jetzt hat es mit rammstein koordiniert
na ja auch den vorstoß gegeben und ich
will eine sache noch mal deutlich sagen
wir haben schon in den letzten tagen
auch berichterstattungen was nicht
glücklich war darüber gehabt dass die
bundesregierung die munition für den
geopark panzer sucht die schweiz hat vor
ein paar tagen gesagt dass sie nicht
bereit sind die zur verfügung zu stellen
und das zeigt ja auch dass das was da
jetzt
wochenanfang passiert ist dass das
vorbereitet wurde in der regierung dass
man das koordiniert hat aber ein
bundeskanzler verkündet so was erst wenn
es beschlossen ist wenn es durch den
bundessicherheitsrat ist ich möchte kein
kanzler der morgens nicht überlegt was
verkündigt heute ich möchte kein kanzler
der wasserstandsmeldungen ab gibt dafür
ist das thema viel zu ernst aber das was
jetzt entschieden ist steht in der
kontinuität der entscheidung der
bundesregierung der waffen also wenn er
so was ist wenn das alles so conzelmann
man hat jetzt im prinzip zwei monate
verspielt in denen man auch die ukraine
ohne ihnen einen einzigen départ vor die
tür zu stellen überhaupt mal erst hätte
er tüchtigen können dass die leute
ausgebildet sind auch das wurde ja
verpasst also das heißt die gesamte im
prinzip was er habe ich von so schön
gesagt hat putin werde mit der realität
konfrontiert die bundesregierung wurde
auch mit der realität konfrontiert wir
alle muss man ja auch sagen das ist ja
nicht so dass wir jetzt alle gut den
experten werden und nur scholz nicht
aber herr scholz hat erst nicht glaube
ich wirklich ist nicht für möglichkeiten
dass die invasion kommt da war wirklich
nicht alleine dann hat er es nicht für
möglich halten dass die ukraine so lange
durchhält jetzt na na das nicht für
möglichkeiten dass der druck die
schweren waffen zu liefern dass es so
wichtig werden könnte dass diese art von
waffen in diesem krieg so wichtig werden
könnte und er hat dann stetig war er
gezwungen seine position der realität
anzupassen und jetzt haben wir die
jüngste kehrtwende erlebt das ist keine
strategie das ist keine geniale
vorausschauende planung das ist
eigentlich das gegenteil dessen was
scholz immer auch von sich selber
versprochen hat was er im kanzleramt
machen würde endlich mal jung reagieren
sondern mal strategisch vorangehen und
damit sind wir bei sabine fischer
verteidigungsexperte frau fischer wenn
das ist ja ein interessantes argument
man kann ja sehr wohl sagen es gibt
viele menschen in diesem land überall
auf der welt die angst vor einem krieg
haben die angst vor genau diesem krieg
haben und das kann man ja auch gut
begründen man kann ja auch sagen dass
man das versteht dass mancher vollzieht
56 prozent der menschen dieses landes
sagen dass gerade das sie fürchten das
ist eine ausweitung des krieges gibt was
würden sie denn an bord
erst mal dass ich diese angst teile ich
habe diese angst auch und ich glaube
alle die wir haben diesen tisch sitzen
haben diese angst und diese befürchtung
aber das was jetzt sich militärisch in
der ukraine abspielt russische angriff
und die damit verbundenen russischen
ziele und motive die machen eben mit der
ukraine nicht halt das heißt wir haben
es mit einem größeren konflikt zu tun ja
die russische seite hat im letten
verlauf des letzten jahres immer klarer
und dann im dezember noch mal ganz
deutlich mit diesem vertragsentwürfen
die da veröffentlicht wurden klar
gemacht dass sie ambitionen hat weit
über ihre unmittelbare nachbarschaft
hinaus das ist wirklich hier geht um
eine neuordnung europäische sicherheit
nach russischen vorstellungen und das
ist etwas was uns alle ziemlich
unmittelbar bedroht und deswegen können
wir uns von diesem krieg in der ukraine
jetzt nicht einfach abwenden und sagen
das ist nicht unser problem es ist unser
problem und je erfolgreicher russland
mit dieser offensive und mit dieser
aggression ist desto größer wird dann
auch das problem weil das natürlich
russland stärken wird und auch ermutigen
wird die sind sehr aggressiven kurs auch
anderen staaten gegenüber
weiterzuführen ich ins ende dieser
formulieren müssen was frau fischer
glauben sie hilft am meisten um putin zu
schaden wenn wir jetzt so viel wie
möglich tun oder wenn wir so vorsichtig
und eben auch hierunter zurückhaltend
sind
also
ich gehe mal vorneweg das ich dass ich
den wunsch und den konsens auch der
koalitionsparteien und ich denke
eigentlich dass ganz des gesamt
politischen spektrums auch im bundestag
das auf keinen fall die nato zur
kriegspartei werden darf den teil ich
absolut ja und ich denke letztendlich
muss die deutsche muss die europäische
politik auf drei säulen auf ruhen wenn
sie so wollen das eine sind sind die
sanktionen ja die mittelfristig dafür
sorgen dass russland die wirtschaftliche
grundlage für für eine aggressive
außenpolitik entzogen wird sanktionen
wirken nicht kurzfristig wirken
mittelfristig hier geht es also darum
einfache für die zukunft zu
verunmöglichen dass russland
wirtschaftlich solche kriege führen kann
aggressive außenpolitik betreiben kann
die waffen für die ukraine da geht es
tatsächlich darum wie weit schafft es
die ukraine diese russische aggression
zurückzudrängen und in dem zusammenhang
würde ich gerne noch mal kurz darauf
verweisen dass ich diese dieses diese
diskussion über krieg und niederlage
wirklich sehr problematisch finde ja das
sind problematische begriffe in diesem
zusammenhang wir müssen genau definieren
was ein erfolg der ukraine sein kann in
diesem krieg und was ein erfolg russland
sein kann in diesem krieg um dann eben
darüber zu einer definition zu kommen
dessen was wir auch tun und die dritte
säule die im moment leider etwas in den
hintergrund geraten es ist natürlich die
der diplomatie ja und auch die ist aber
wahnsinnig stark davon abhängig welche
genau welche situation wir am ende
militärisch in der ukraine haben wie
stark die ukraine aus diesen
kampfhandlungen hervorgehen kann wie
stark russland daraus hervorgehen kann
und wie dann das gewicht der beiden
parteien in diesen verhandlungen ist ja
nun sind wir genau auf diesem feld auch
nicht besonders stark weil wir
wahnsinnig abhängig sind von russischer
energie herr merz und da ist das problem
dass wir eben nun auch nach dieser
militärischen hilfe ersucht werden
und von vielen experten eigentlich von
allen gesagt bekommen deutschlands
beitrag in bezug auf diese panzer auf
dieses militärische gerät wird ohnehin
nicht mehr sein als ein symbolischer akt
wenn man das so zusammenfasst
wozu dann eigentlich diese diskussion um
etwas was wir
jetzt politisch mit so viel mühe und
auch mit so viel schaden erwürgt haben
freunde ich teile diese analyse nicht
dass das nur ein symbolischer akt ist
ich glaube dass das sehr praktisch wird
auch in der lieferung der waffensysteme
der gepard das habe ich jetzt auch in
den letzten tagen gelernt ist ja das
komplizierteste waffensystem was wir
anbieten können es gibt einfachere als
den gepard wir haben auch keine munition
für den geradlinigen
auch gerade nochmal gesagt wir könnten
das auch gerne behalten wenn wir nicht
die munition nach vielen galt wohl in
brasilien noch ein größerer munitions
bestand den man vielleicht dazu
mobilisieren könnte aber es geht ja auch
um die schritte dorthin und die
ukrainische armee auch in die lage zu
versetzen das land weiter zu verteilen
wir helfen hier einem land bei der von
der uno charta eindeutig gedeckten und
geregelten selbstverteidigung gegen eine
solche aggression und da will ich mich
gar nicht jetzt in die militärischen
details verlieren die kenne ich auch
nicht nur aber auch da präziser
formulieren sein es werden nicht viele
panzer seien die wir bei stellen können
das hat frau lamprecht heute nicht nur
heute ausführlich geschildert über
welche möglichkeiten die müssen jetzt
auch erstmal wieder ganz gemacht werden
ist bei dem gepard gesagt wann werden
die also habe ich eine sei schon fast
jede einschätzung der lage gehört das
ist nicht der maßstab an dem ich mich
orientieren
wir haben waffen die die bundeswehr
liefern kann in begrenzter zahl wir
haben waffensysteme die die industrie
liefern kann die dort teilweise
eingelagert sind die sollen jetzt auch
mobilisiert werden und die entscheidende
frage ist ja frau fischer hat indirekt
angesprochen wie lange dauert das
eigentlich noch und wie weit wird sich
dieser krieg möglicherweise noch
ausweiten wir müssen heute wohl davon
ausgehen dass es noch länger dauert und
dass er sich möglicherweise auch auf
moldau schon überträgt da gibt es erste
hinweise und das ziel muss sein nicht
dass der eine gewinnt und der andere
verliert sondern dass man hier zu einem
stopp kommt dessen was putin zur zeit in
seiner aggression tut und dass man ihn
auch zwingt diesen krieg zu beenden und
auch das land wieder freizugeben und den
ukrainern das recht auf selbstbestimmung
zurückzugeben ich glaube das ist die
richtige musik und einer verlierer ja
also dass er holt sich so weil er den
krieg sagte hubert habe gerade in etwas
martialischen worten gesagt mit einer
maschine in moskau das ist ja nicht der
punkt um den unsere ukraine übrigens
auch nicht
dass doch ein sieg wenn sogar die
separatisten gebiete wieder unter
ukrainischer kontrolle werden
definiert im rahmen der verhandlungen
die gelaufen sind die
hamburger die sehr an
sie haben gesagt wir möchten erreichen
dass die russischen truppen sich
zurückziehen hinter die kontakt linie
vom 24 4 punkten und wir wollen einen
verhandlungsprozess über den status der
krim in einem zeitraum von 15 jahren das
sind die beiden ganz konkret
formulierten militärischen garantie für
kiew ziele nicht ins auto
kiew hat angeboten neutralität in
kombination mit starken
sicherheitsgarantien und das ist
wirklich ein junktim also das eine wird
es ohne das andere nicht geben und
natürlich ist es das übergreifende
überwölbende ziel der ukraine der erhalt
und die stärkung der eigenen
staatlichkeit gegen diese russische
aggression das ist ganz klar umrissen
ist auch überhaupt nicht schwer
nachzuvollziehen darf ich noch einen
punkt machen bitte weil ich immer ein
bisschen unzufrieden bin wenn wenn
symbolik so vom tisch gewischt wird in
diesem zusammenhang ich finde symbolik
sehr sehr wichtig ich finde politische
signale sehr sehr wichtig ja und ich
meine wir sind uns alle klar dass die
bundeswehr in keinem guten zustand ist
ja dass wir im vergleich zu dem was
deutschland wirtschaftlich darstellt
politisch darstellt nicht so viel zu
bieten haben aber es ist trotzdem enorm
wichtig dass das eben gegeben wird
soweit ein symbolischer schritt genau
sollten um sekunde zitiere noch mal es
ist ein unterschied ob ich erkläre dass
ich etwas nicht kann oder ob ich erkläre
dass ich etwas nicht will und das
problem der letzten acht wochen war das
ist zwischen diesen argumenten wirklich
schreckliche man damit hat scholz die
ganze symbole kaputtgemacht muss man ja
sagen auch jetzt seiner kerpen also die
die dinge die deutschland geleistet hat
wurden ja durch diese kleinkarierte
debatte insofern finde ich frage völlig
berechtigt müssen wir da jetzt noch ewig
langen war es notwendig so lange zu
diskutieren über diese frage schwere
waffen ja oder nein nicht vorgegangen
sind irgendwie ich will das einfach noch
mal betonen weil die wiederholten mal in
den raum gestellt wird dass andere
länder diese entscheidung vorher
getroffen hätten das stimmt einfach
nicht nennen sie mir das land das
westliche panzer vor deutschland jetzt
der bundesregierung sowohl die kanadier
deutschland die bewegung als auch die
usa wir haben
sonntag gesagt die niederlande das haben
wir vor dieser woche gesagt dass wir die
niederlande zum beispiel bei der frage
panzerhaubitzen mit munition und
ausbildung unterstützen klar das ist
keine liefern von schweren waffen aber
trotzdem sind wir den weg gegangen aber
es wird auch hier der eindruck erweckt
auch in dem in dem beitrag vor hin dass
andere länder da viel mehr machen würden
und das ist nicht der fall und nochmal
es macht auch ein unterschied ob ich
lief also es ist das gleich ob ich
liefern kann und ob ich im bündnis
entschieden habe dass auch geliefert
wird und wenn wir zum beispiel sehen das
ist die mader dass wir die für den
ringtausch einschätzen können was ja
übersetzt heißt das andere
osteuropäische länder dass die
sowjetische panzer liefern können diese
sofort eingesetzt werden können die
nicht erst in drei monaten kommt dann
sondern auch keine sofort helfen dann
ist mir das lieber dass wir das machen
als dass wir hier die maler tüchtigen
und sie irgendwann in vier fünf monaten
über schicken was machen sie denn wenn
jetzt in ein paar wochen wieder etwas
geschieht was bisher kategorisch
ausgeschlossen wurde nochmal am
verreisen sie hat herr frontzeck sowohl
auf scholz' die lieferung von panzern
kategorisch ausgeschlossen hat ich hätte
ihnen vom kiosk eins mitbringen
gemeinsam eine so funktioniert der
politik nicht fähig hatte das manager
geäußert in dem moment wo das im
bundessicherheitsrat im westlichen
bündnis entschieden aber er klingt auch
nochmals in der politik als ich haben
bundeskanzler ist klein aber doch der
sollte nicht radstands melden leben
sondern entscheidung verkünden und am
liebsten ist wie wenn die entscheidung
in einer kriegssituation in einer frage
wo es um leben und tod geht mit den
alliierten koordiniert sind und nicht
deutschland mehr lange scholz hatte in
dem interview das am ich glaube online
ist es freitagmittag erschienen hat er
ohne not ohne druck den kontext
hergestellt zwischen unserer frage die
nach schweren waffen gingen da kam dann
diese flugverbotszone zwischendurch noch
sei ja aber die frage war nach schweren
waffen haben wir auch noch mal
nachgehakt wenn man zwei weiteren fragen
nachgehakt und er hat den kontext
hergestellt schwere waffen atomkrieg das
lesen die leute die umfragen man darf
sich nicht wundern wenn die mehrheit der
deutschen ja auch sagt um gottes willen
wir wollen das nicht jetzt ist aber doch
so dass die bundesregierung es ja macht
das heißt der kontext ist da von
bundeskanzler selber gesetzt der kontext
schwere waffen und atomkrieg ist da und
jetzt liefern wir schwere waffen und
fallstudien sehen lassen das kann pokale
ist etwas dabei was damit verbunden ist
mit dieser botschaft das ist ja kein
wunder dass die leute angst haben da
draußen und was ist denn jetzt der
nächste schritt in drei wochen werden
wir darüber sprechen vielleicht über die
marder der oder den usa steckt sich
weinend weil die regierung noch das ist
dieser krieg ja und sie haben vorhin
gesagt der bundeskanzler ist dann kriegs
anfang davon ausgegangen dass das nach
ein paar tagen beendet ist ich war vier
tage vor beginn dieses krieges in
münchen auf der sicherheitskonferenz wo
2000 sehr gut bezahlte experten die
regel reichlich 30 seien aber die sind
doch alle davon ausgegangen dass dieser
kapital schlagen so und und jetzt ist
doch eine bundesregierung die im
täglichen sich mit den partnern beraten
muss was passiert wenn der reiniger
entwickelt haben sie hätten wir von dir
geben sie ja dann haben wir natürlich
ist das lob des apothekers mit
amerikanern geredet die alle sagen dass
die amerikaner ist so vielseitig wie
teuer so konnte sie auf rammstein was da
ausgesprochen wurde von unseren
amerikanischen partnern es gibt eine
enge kooperation und ich natürlich
nämlich auch war wie die debatte in
deutschland läuft ich lese auch die
artikel die veröffentlicht werden ich
bin auch nicht damit zufrieden wie
gerade die berichterstattung über das
ist was hier das ist auch um pr bitte
sagen was ist ihnen wichtig passiert ist
es war wichtig dass das so passiert ist
und ich frage den oppositionsführer
jetzt nochmal wie zufrieden in
anführungsstrichen herr merz sind sie
mit dem ergebnis dieses tages wird man
zusammenfassen als gepard gestartet und
als bettvorleger gelandet
sie meinen die regierung ich frage die
opposition also ich
in dieser diskussion kann ich nicht mit
so einer kategorie ich bin zufrieden
arbeiten wir sind in aller eile in einer
extrem schwierigen situation und wir
haben heute ein bundestagsvotum in
diesen fragen herbeigeführt das ist auch
unser verdienst dass das überhaupt
stattgefunden hat kann die forderung
nach mehr geben es kann morgen die
forderung nach den pumas geben nach den
luchsen nach den mördern es kann sein so
sehen wir richtigen wir uns mit dieser
situation wir sind doch jetzt erst mal
an einem punkt wo klar ist dass
deutschland jetzt endlich liefert und
auch klarheit verschafft hat und übriger
klingbeil sie verweisen immer wieder auf
den bundessicherheitsrat das ist eine
erstaunliche argumentation sie sind
nicht mitglied dieses
bundessicherheitsrates die sitzungen
sind geheim wir wissen weder wann sie
stattfinden noch wissen wir was da
beschlossen worden ist wenn sie mehr
wissen was habe ich ihm gesagt nein sie
verweisen immer wieder auf die arbeit
haben die entscheidung getroffen die
andere richtung aber sie können doch
nicht auf diese entscheidungen verweisen
sie können die und dürfen die gar nicht
kennen aber ich habe doch keine
entscheidung die verweisen immer wieder
darauf dass da alle möglichen beschlüsse
gefasst worden sind ja also das nicht
verständlich genug nein das ist
natürlich ist die entscheidung sie den
geparden ist doch getroffen worden im
bundessicherheitsrat aber dann ist das
haben sie doch was isst richtung kann
nur sie haben in den letzten wochen
immer wieder begründet da würden alle
möglichen klugen entscheidungen
getroffen diese entscheidung ist das
zuständige gremium widerrufen worden und
es ist auch wahr dass die amerikaner
mehr liefern als alle europäer zusammen
und dann zu behaupten deutschland würde
sich da immer im gleitflug der
alliierten bewegen ist einfach ein das
ist eine nebelkerze die werfen sie aber
schon seit wochen weil sie in dieser
koalition bis zum heutigen tag keine
einigkeit gehabt haben wir haben sie
seit heute das ist auch in ordnung so
sollen jetzt müssen wir alle sehen dass
wir den nächsten schritt abwarten was
passiert ich hoffe dass die ukraine
soweit ertüchtigt wird dass sie in der
lage ist diese ziel die frau fischer
eben glaube ich sehr klug und sehr
vernünftig auch hier dargelegt hat
erreicht und dann hoffen wir dass das
bald beendet ist und nicht noch weiter
eskaliert und dass der bundeskanzler
dann in diesem zusammenhang vom dritten
weltkrieg und einem atomkrieg spricht
ich halte das für unverantwortlich zumal
er ist in dem kontext seiner politischen
entscheidungen trifft frau ein mann hat
sie gerade dargestellt die drei tage
später schon wieder so aussehen als ob
er jetzt selber den dritten weltkrieg
herbeiführen das passt alles nicht
zusammen nicht die kommunikation die
ganze strategie dieser bundesregierung
stimmt hinten und vorne nicht gott sei
dank haben wir seit heute etwas mehr
klarheit in diesen fragen und es wäre
gut wenn der bundeskanzler diese linie
beibehält und nicht jetzt wieder anfängt
fragen zu beantworten die ihm keiner
stellt aber alle fragen die ihm gestellt
wird nicht beantwortet wie sie sind ich
habe sie danach schon gefragt sie sind
auch nicht nur umgeben von politikern
von kollegen herr merz die vorbehaltlos
das unterstützen was man jetzt eine
militärische aufrüstung nennt in bezug
auf das was in der ukraine geschehen
soll
da habe ich schon zitiert oder besser
gesagt ich könnte das noch ausführlicher
tun ich mache mir große sorgen wie der
konflikt weiter geht deutschland steht
in der gefahr dass sie sich in den von
russland begonnenen angriffskrieg
hineinziehen lässt das ist immerhin ihr
der csu vorsitzende und bayerische
ministerpräsident
also ich verstehe und habe verstanden
was sie der regierung sagen wollen aber
wie geschlossen sind ihre reihen also
wir haben in der letzten woche einen
antrag in den bundestag eingebracht der
einstimmig verabschiedet wurde hat war
der ecke das ist relativ schnell
gegangen als wir gesehen haben dass wir
jetzt handeln müssen das haben wir dann
auch getan wir hatten heute im bundestag
eine gegenstimme die sozialdemokraten
keine insofern können wir sagen wir sind
hier in einer großen geschlossenheit
auch heute durch die abstimmung gegangen
dass wir uns sorgen machen um die lage
dass wir alle auch befürchten dass es
eine solche eskalation geben könnte ist
der eine teil aber wir müssen doch
nüchtern auch die frage beantworten wie
begegnen wird diesen fest es ist ein
genuss hat ja ein paar wochen davor auch
noch gerade gefordert schwere waffen an
die ukraine zu liefern also da ehrlich
da irrlichtert er zwischen seinen
positionen fast ein bisschen wie mit der
bundeskanzler aber was ich nämlich herr
merz ist wieso sie heute das hat ja
klingbeil in der debatte ja dann auch
angesprochen sie haben gemeinsamen
antrag mit der koalition und halten dann
ein rede in der sie den kanzler
filetieren als auf eine art und weise
man denkt haben die nicht eigentlichen
gemeinsamen antrag da steht doch auch
irgendwie name der name friedrich merz
drunter und trotzdem treten sie dann auf
und verreisen der luft also sind sie
jetzt bei jedem in dem bei dem thema
oder sind sie haben bei antrag in den
letzten beraten und gemeinsam
beschlossen aber dass ich noch mal zur
entstehungsgeschichte dieses antrags
etwas sage und warum es überhaupt
notwendig geworden ist dass der
bundestag sich damit beschäftigt das ist
doch wohl völlig selbstverständlich
hätte meine aufgabe nicht erfüllt wenn
ich das heute nicht gesagt hätte
man das soll noch übrig bleiben wir sind
verbunden und das ist vielleicht eine
gute stelle in dieser sendung mit
helsinki und in helsinki nicht mit
irgendjemandem sondern mit dem
ehemaligen oberbefehlshaber der us
landstreitkräfte
in europa er ist heute berater für
logistik manager es einen guten abend zu
ihnen
hallo madrid sie müssen uns gleich bei
der beantwortung vieler fragen helfen
punkt nummer eins wie zufrieden ist die
us regierung glauben sie mit dem was die
deutsche regierung bisher für die
ukraine getan hat und im verbund getan
hat
natürlich würden wir gerne sehen dass
unser wichtigster verbündeter weiterhin
eine führungsrolle in europa einnimmt
anderen nationen beobachten genau was
deutschland tut aber ich glaube es war
wichtig dass diese entscheidung der
bundesrepublik jetzt getroffen wurde die
versorgung auch der und mit der art und
weise der versorgung und der art und
weise des materials das zur verfügung
gestellt wird erhöht wird und ich hab
schon früher angedeutet dass deutschland
nicht wirklich die anerkennung für das
erhält was deutschland schon getan hat
es gibt da eine gewisse skepsis
gegenüber den gründen weshalb bestimmte
dinge nicht passiert sind und dass diese
gründe sich verändert haben in den
vergangenen tagen in der öffentlichen
argumentation aber tatsächlich wurde
schon viel getan und die menge an
munition die zur verfügung gestellt wird
und wurde ist wichtig und es gibt
natürlich noch einige andere politische
entscheidung die deutschland getroffen
auch das ist von bedeutung aber
letztlich ist es was mir und auch
unserer regierung am wichtigsten ist ist
dass die vereinigten staaten und
deutschland
gemeinsam auftreten und das gleiche ziel
verfolgen und das ist da die ukraine
erfolgreich ist dass die ukraine
tatsächlich gewinnen kann und dass sie
es schaffen ihre territoriale integrität
wiederherzustellen hier geht es um den
widerspruch zwischen demokratie und
autokratie und deswegen ist das denke
ich das wichtigste für die wir machen
müssen ist ein bisschen konkreter machen
vielleicht kann ich anfangen mit der
frage sie sind spezialisiert jetzt auf
eben in allererster linie logistische
fragen wie gut kommen die waffen der
nato wie gut kommen die ausrüstungen des
westens in der ukraine überhaupt an und
kommen sie rechtzeitig
im augenblick haben wir da tatsächlich
noch probleme
das material ist jetzt in polen in der
slowakei rumänien und natürlich arbeiten
die menschen sehr schwer daran dieses
material auch in die ukraine zu bringen
aber aufgrund der politischen
entscheidung dass also das eben keine us
oder deutschen oder britischen truppen
in die ukraine gehen können muss alles
von den ukrainern abgeholt werden und
dann in die ukraine an die front
verbracht werden wo dieses material
gebraucht wird und das bedeutet mehrere
hundert kilometer transportweg und zwar
über eine weniger als ideale
infrastruktur das ist eine große
herausforderung und ich glaube dass auch
die logistischen systeme des
ukrainischen militärs im augenblick
natürlich nicht unbedingt darauf
ausgelegt ist
diese art von belastung abzufangen und
das ist denke ich auch die achillesferse
der gesamten operation dass das material
nicht wirklich so an die front kommt
nicht so schnell an die front kommt wie
nötig und ganz besonders für die
nächsten wochen wird das eine echte
herausforderung sein und bleiben aber
ich habe den eindruck dass das im laufe
der zeit dann tatsächlich reifen wird
und hoffentlich ist es noch nicht zu
spät wie viel zeit haben wir noch wäre
die nächste frage wir erinnern uns ben
hodges an diese geschichte mit den mix
mit den kampfflugzeugen die die polen
liefern wollten in die ukraine und oder
washington eigentlich nicht liefern
wollte sie sollten dann nicht über polen
in die ukraine gehen und am ende kam es
nicht zu dieser lieferung zu dieser
belieferung
was ist jetzt an haubitzen und an
panzern anders was ist an der artillerie
anders als eben an einem solchen an
solch einer solchen weg
ich habe da durchaus verständnis für
einige dieser diskussion die in der
koalitionsregierung geführt worden es
war nur vor wenigen wochen das auch
unser präsident darüber argumentierten
hat ob er überhaupt stinger zur
verfügung stellen sollten also das sind
tragbare
warten und das war vor sieben wochen und
wir haben da sehr viel zeit damit
vergeudet darüber zu entscheiden was
geliefert werden soll und herr klingbeil
hat völlig recht wenn er sagt dass es
kein amerikanischen panzer in der
ukraine gibt keine infanterie fahrzeuge
in der ukraine amerikanischer bauart
gibt und ich glaube wir alle haben
schwierigkeiten damit gehabt zu
entscheiden wie man die balance
herstellen zwischen dem schutz des
ukrainischen volkes und ihnen dabei zu
helfen ihre eigene souveränität zu
schützen und gleichzeitig eine
eskalation zu vermeiden das ist etwas
was niemand wünscht aber ich denke dass
zwei dinge sich geändert haben zunächst
einmal haben wir alle natürlich
schockierend erlebt wie unschuldige
ukrainer und ukrainerinnen ermordet
worden wir haben alle die bilder gesehen
von menschen die hingerichtet getötet
worden sind die auf den straßen von gut
schlagen und ich glaube das hat
tatsächlich dazu geführt dass die
menschen ihre ansichten geändert haben
einschließlich und meines präsidenten
und vielleicht auch des bundeskanzlers
und ich glaube niemand möchte einfach
nur dasitzen das sehen und nicht
reagieren das war glaube ich ein
wichtiger unterschied aber ich glaube
darüber hinaus auch dass es
tatsächlich eine art
reifung eine weiterentwicklung der
entscheidungsfindung gibt im weißen haus
und auch in anderen hauptstädten bei der
einsicht dass der kreml uns ja schon
jahren bedroht hat und wir diese
bedrohung natürlich nicht auf die
leichte schulter genommen habe ich habe
auch familie und freunde in deutschland
menschen die auch während des krieges
damals junge menschen waren und ich war
sehr wie sie darauf reagieren und welche
erinnerungen wachgerufen werden und
deswegen kann ich die bedenken verstehen
die die menschen haben die wir alle
haben aber ich glaube dass das weiße
haus dass der bundeskanzler und auch die
premierminister anderer länder
anerkennen dass die einzige art und
weise wie wir das aufhalten können daran
besteht dass wir zusammen agieren und
zwar sehr entschieden und nicht nur
einfach hoffen dass es auf wir müssen
agieren wir müssen handeln und deswegen
müssen handeln und hier kommt da vorher
noch eine frage es gibt eine
interessante äußerung des us
verteidigungsministers wir wollen
nämlich fragen mit welchem ziel müssen
wir eigentlich handeln und agieren und
haben von lloyd austin einen neuen fokus
genannt bekommen
nach seinem besuch bei präsident
selensky in kiew verkündete
us-verteidigungsminister lloyd austin
wir wollen russland in dem ausmaß
geschwächt sehen dass es das was es mit
dem einmarsch in die ukraine getan hat
nicht mehr machen kann
und wir wollen dass sie ihre
militärischen fähigkeiten nicht zu
schnell wieder aufbauen können
russland nachhaltig schwächen ist dass
das neue ziel des westens
bisher hat die usa haben die usa keine
panzer geliefert bisher hat joe biden
das wort sieg nicht in den mund genommen
jetzt sagt der verteidigungsminister
dass man russland nachhaltig schwächen
möchte ist das ein neues ziel
nun das ziel
besteht darin dass die demokratie will
autokratie besiegt und dass wir die
menschliche würde schützen und die
souveränität von souveränen staaten
respektieren wenn also der
außenwelt entschuldigung der
verteidigungsminister aus den sagt dass
wir dabei helfen wollen dass sie
gewinnen und dass russland so geschwächt
werden soll dass die nachbarn nicht mehr
bedroht werden können dann sehen sie
dass es um mehr geht als nur um die
ukraine es geht um alle in der
peripherie russlands und darum sie zu
schützen gegenüber der russischen
möglichen aggression und das ist
natürlich ein anderer politikansatz aber
das muss auch vom präsidenten kommen der
verteidigungsminister aus denn hat
natürlich diesen politikansatz nicht
selbst entworfen er führt hier auch
anweisungen des präsidenten aus und das
ist ganz wichtig dass wir hier über das
siegen sprechen und natürlich wurde ich
auch schon auf das treffen angesprochen
in ramstein wo alle sich getroffen haben
und solche
solche treffen sind wichtig und die
tatsache dass ist 40 länder waren nicht
nur die nato die hier eine rolle
gespielt haben das ist ein sehr wirklich
starkes signal wir sind noch bei der
frage frau fischer wenn die ukraine nun
auch ertüchtigt werden soll dass sie
sich gegen russische angriffe wert und
zwar nicht nur auf ihrem territorium
sondern gegebenenfalls eben auch auf
russischem territorium
das kam jetzt heute über die agenturen
ist das dann schon ein zeichen dafür
dass wir auch über ein neues ziel
nachdenken also laufen sie nicht ich
wäre mit diesen meldungen die wir heute
gesehen haben extrem vorsichtig wir
wissen nicht genau was da passiert ist
genauso wie wir nicht genau wissen was
eigentlich in transnistrien also in
dieser abtrünnigen in diesem abtrünnigen
gebiet in moldawien passiert ist wir
wissen es einfach
genau es gibt da eine reihe von
interpretationsmöglichkeiten und ich
wäre extrem vorsichtig auch darin
sozusagen die ukrainische seite jetzt
aufzufordern oder zu ermutigen
russisches territorium anzugreifen ja
also ich meine das denn man kann
argumentieren dass ich glaube in einer
meldung hieß es ein signal auch an die
russische bevölkerung sein kann dass
putin sie nicht schützen kann ich halte
das für ziemlich riskant ich würde auf
keinen fall dazu ermutigen und noch mal
kurz was zur schwächung da geht mir ein
bisschen zu viel durcheinander ich meine
wir haben vorhin über die sanktionen
gesprochen und sie haben recht man
natürlich dass das ist aber es geht um
eine militärische lösung sonst würde es
nicht der verteidigungsminister sagen so
also wenigstens stünde dass zu vermuten
da wir sehen dass ich auch schon ganz
anders gesagt wenn ich das noch kurz
sagen auf die beiden ist ja schon
rausgerutscht oder nachher die besucher
im ruth schafft wieder einzufangen dass
er gesagt hat es geht auch darum
wladimir putins herrschaft zu beenden
und es stimmt ja das ist schon etwas
älter das ist aber das muss man im
hinterkopf haben ich glaube wir müssen
aufpassen wie wir sprechen wir müssen
klar seinem handeln und ich glaube das
paket aus sanktionen als militärische
unterstützung der ukraine auch aus
politischem druck der da ist dadurch
dass der westen so geschlossen agiert
wie in den letzten zehn 15 jahren nicht
das ist ein wichtiges zeichen aber es
geht nicht darum russland zu besiegen
sondern es geht darum zu erreichen dass
russland nicht gemäß ansetzen und dann
klug und dann glaube ich dass wir in
sachen landen und sagt deutlich die
ukraine muss gewinnen und wir müssen sie
ertüchtigen aber sich zu verteidigen der
punkt dass putin diesen krieg angefangen
hat und dachte dass er dort empfangen
würde das alle wahrnehmen dass ich noch
mal ein sehr weit ja ich würde es aber
nur sagen es geht darum dass putin nicht
erfolgreich ist das ist eine massive
schwächung weil es auch bedeuten wird
dass er von weiteren plänen andere
länder anzugreifen abstand nehmen wird
es wird zum beispiel auch glaube ich die
chinesen gucken ganz genau hin was sie
in taiwan machen und werden sehen wenn
putin keinen erfolg hat wird das auch
für china konsequenzen haben und
deswegen ist es wichtig dass wir die
ukraine so ertüchtigen dass sie eine
chance haben zu gewinnen bzw
putin eine putin zu stoppen und dafür zu
sorgen dass wir keine angst wir können
vielleicht auch ein bisschen anders
kommuniziert werden damit auch die
abgeordneten fraktionen und von fdp und
grünen sie in nicht missverstehen bei
dem versuch ein welches schnell ist es
passiert naja also sonst hätte sich
glaube ich vor strack zimmermann und
herr hofreiter und herr mützenich nicht
sind die sind jetzt nicht in einer
balance zu sehen ich will nur sagen die
beschwerde darüber was und wie
interpretiert werden kann und muss im
sinne dieser regierung die haben wir
jetzt nicht erfunden also
ich hab mir gerade gesagt bin auch nicht
über jede kommunikation glücklich und
ich über jede stimme die sich der home
hat aber das was wir heute im parlament
gesehen haben ein wirklich von allen
unterstützter antrag die ampel steht die
union ist dazugekommen das ist doch das
wichtige signal und ben hodges hat es
gerade gesagt die transatlantische
zusammenarbeit ist es super wichtig wir
sind fragt man noch mal bei der
politischen frage nach vorn wie stabil
ist diese regierung um nächste neue das
war ihr punkt vorhin um nächste neue
gegebenenfalls auch massive militärische
beteiligungen zu entscheiden ich fürchte
dass wir dieselbe debatte in einem monat
wieder haben werden nur bezüglich
anderen kriegsgeräte also im moment
zumindest sehe ich dieses problem nicht
gelöst weil also herr mützenich ihr
fraktionschef das ist ja jetzt nicht
irgendein hinterbänkler hat ja noch
anfang der woche gesagt ihm sei diese
ganze debatte irgendwie zu
militaristisch das heißt wenn sie jetzt
sagen wir müssen auf jeden fall die
ukraine ertüchtigen dann weiß man im
moment nicht was bedeutet das also man
weiß es jetzt in diesem moment aber man
weiß es nicht was bedeutet dass in den
nächsten wochen es ist ja richtig zu
sagen wir stimmen uns mit den
bündnispartnern ab aber deutschland ist
ja nun nicht irgendein land oder
zumindest hätte ich jetzt gedacht dass
das selbstverständnis der
bundesregierung ist nicht irgendein land
zu stehen dass damit schwimmt wie ein
mittelgroßes europäisches land das
wirtschaftlich vielleicht ein bisschen
wackelig da steht wir reden über das
reichste stärkste auch von seiner
rüstungsindustrie her stärkste land in
europa und das die meisten waffenexporte
hat und da fehlt einfach eine
führungsrolle von herrn scholz da fehlt
mir
im prinzip finde ich habe ich heute
abend hier von unseren mitdiskutanten
schon mehr gehört insbesondere von ihnen
was mittelfristig strategien sind und
von herrn habeck vor als von olaf scholz
in dieser gesamten phase und da geht es
nicht nur um kommunikation da geht es
auch einfach um die haltung ist die
haltung nicht klar in welche richtung
sich deutschland bewegen soll und wie
weit wir gehen werden ich frag nochmal
ben hodges einmal nach helsinki was wird
das ziel des westens sein und muss am
ende auch das wird in deutschland
diskutiert nicht etwas wie minsk plus
also wieder ein verhandlungsergebnis
darauf machte frau fischer aufmerksam im
raume stehen und muss man das
gegebenenfalls mit wladimir putin
verhandeln eben weil er nicht weg sein
wird
nun zunächst einmal
gilt es um die frage was das verständnis
angeht was gewinnen bedeutet der kreml
hat heute das signal ein sehr starkes
signal ausgesendet
un-generalsekretär war heute in kiew
einen tag nachdem er in moskau und zwei
russische raketen sind in der stadt kef
eingeschlagen während coach er ist da
war das zeigt doch wie wenig der kreml
die un respektiert und deswegen ist es
so wichtig dass wir zusammenhalten das
ist einheitliches vorgehen unter den
alliierten und den partnern geht auch
bei der vorstellung dessen was der
gewünschte das gewünschte ergebnis ist
es geht hier um die souveränität des
landes es geht um demokratie und es muss
auch um menschliche würde gehen und das
bedeutet dass russland zurückgedrängt
werden muss auf die linie vor dem 24
februar die hunderttausende ukrainer und
ukrainerinnen gekidnappt und deportiert
worden sind müssen sofort wieder zurück
nach hause gebracht werden und dann
braucht es eine langfristige
verpflichtung von uns allen
das nämlich letztlich die ukrainische
souveränität wieder hergestellt wurde
sowie die vereinigten staaten
beispielsweise während des kalten
krieges nie die annektierung der
baltischen staaten anerkannt hat sollten
wir jetzt den russischen ansprüchen der
krim keine legitimität verleihen und ich
denke wenn wir alle zusammenhalten dann
wird die souveränität der ukraine wieder
hergestellt werden können der prozess
nun ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher wie
die aussieht aber ich bin ganz sicher
dass deutschland hier eine sehr wichtige
rolle spielen würde mich handeln frau
fischer ist es vorstellbar dass wir
sogar irgendwie die also dass die
ukrainische truppen nicht wie
entschuldigung dass die ukrainischen
truppen schaffen die krim wieder zu
erobern oder
ich bin keine militärexperten ja ich
halte das für relativ unwahrscheinlich
und ich verweise wieder auf die
verhandlungsposition der ukrainischen
also eine art mini sehr realistisch ist
ja ich wäre vorsichtig mit dem begriff
minsk ich würde den so ist verhalten der
ukraine ja nicht nur das sondern
russland hat also dieses minsker
abkommen hat acht jahre lang den rahmen
gestellt für die verhandlungen geführt
worden sind um diesen konflikten
einigermaßen unter kontrolle zu halten
russland hat mit der anerkennung der
beiden sogenannten volksrepublik im
donbass im organischen donbass am 21
februar des minsker abkommen
aufgekündigt deswegen und wir sind heute
in einer völlig anderen sind wo ich sage
es als 2000 ich hätte auf den kompromiss
wie ein handy lenski verweisen sollen
also muss man sich am ende mit putin
einigen man also wenn die situation
eintritt die die ukraine als ihr
kriegsziel sagen wir mal oder ihr
verteidigungs ziel definiert hat ja dann
wird die rub und die ukraine hat ja
verhandelt mit der russischen seite bis
ende märz ja das ist jetzt bis dann
wurden nach genau istanbul boccia und
diese entsetzlich keiten die da entdeckt
worden sind haben erstmal eine
verhandlungspause bewirkt aber ich denke
diese verhandlungen werden irgendwann
weitergehen und ich glaube so
realistisch muss man sein und sind die
ukraine tatsächlich auch dass sie sich
eben trotz dieser mörderischen
aggressionen mit der russischen seite an
den tisch gesetzt haben um zu verhandeln
das heißt irgendwann werden sie an
diesen verhandlungstisch zurückkehren
und dann die vorhin schon gesagt wird es
ganz stark davon abhängen wie stark die
ukraine militärisch ist welche erfolge
sie erzählt hat wie wie stark sie eben
auch in diesen verhandlungen sein kann
es ist eine offene frage weil wir das
einfach noch nicht wissen aber wir
können eben viel dafür tun dass sie
stärker wird und das ist das zentrale in
meinen augen wird sehr märz die frage an
sie zum schluss wird dass die deutsche
bevölkerung
mitmachen es ist erstaunlich dass die
sorge unter den menschen sehr groß ist
dass der krieg eskaliert es ist
bemerkenswert dass und wie vorsichtig
die menschen sind lassen die sich würden
sie sagen da angst machen oder ist es
eine berechtigte sorge dass das auch
ganz anders ausgehen kann die sorgen
teilen wir alle und deswegen ist ja auch
besonnenheit in dieser lage richtig aber
auch entschlossenheit und diese
entschlossenheit muss dazu führen dass
die waffen schweigen und das russland
egal in welcher politischen
konstellation gezwungen wird an den
verhandlungstisch zurückzukehren und
auch dieser waffenstillstand wenn wir
denn einmal so weit sind auch
eingehalten wird und da hat die ukraine
extrem schlechte erfahrungen gemacht sie
war mal die drittgrößte atommacht der
welt er hat alles abgegeben und die
garantie gegeben dass die staatliche
souveränität gewahrt wird und das ist
dabei rausgekommen
russland wird das nicht nicht nur
russland auch frankreich und
großbritannien aber man muss einfach
dafür sorgen dass dies jetzt wirklich
irgendwann zunächst einmal von den
reinen kriegerischen handlungen gestoppt
und das müsse das ziel sein und ich
würde nicht denn das wort verwenden dass
die ukraine diesen krieg gewinnt das ist
aus meiner sicht die falsche rhetorik
die die waffen müssen schweigen und dazu
muss man die ukraine tüchtig interessant
dass sich sagen marina weisband von den
gründen sei es letzte woche hier bei uns
und sagte ein sieg der ukraine würde ja
darin bestehen dass man die russischen
truppen an die grenze der ukraine
nämlich aus dem land heraus bekommt
keiner käme auf die idee seitens der
ukraine russisches territorium erobern
zu weit und das steht ja auch gar nicht
zur diskussion dass wäre der sieg aus
der sicht der ukraine in dem augenblick
wo die russische armee so stark
dezimiert ist dass sie nicht mehr
weiterkämpfen kann ist dieser teil
erreicht den wir jetzt erreichen müssen
und dann wird man weitersehen müssen und
man auf diplomatischem wege die nächsten
schritte einleiten kann aber bis dahin
müssen wir kommen und da sind wir noch
längst nicht wir müssen hier einen punkt
machen ich darf mich ganz herzlich
bedanken auch noch mal nach helsinki
danken und wenn der festen überzeugung
dass sie bei markus lanz jetzt in den
besten händen sind liebe zuschauer er
hat unter anderem thomas de maizière zu
gast wir sehen uns wenn sie mögen
nächsten donnerstag wieder gleiche
stelle gleiche welle 22.15 dieses
programm bis dahin kommen sie gut durch
die zeit dankeschön henkel